it's time for our seen and unseen
segment where we explore some of the big
cultural stories of the day comedian nor
McDonald has ahead of Tonight Show
appearance next after some controversial
remarks on the me to movement but that's
far from the whole story joining us now
with more is Raymond Arroyo Fox News
contributor New York Times bestselling
author of the will Wilder series Raymond
I know how the Fallon show canceled Norm
Macdonald oh no why
well NBC says they did it out of
sensitivity to the audience Norma
Connell did an interview about this new
Netflix talk show he's join David
Letterman is producing this is hardly a
conservative talk show at all however
he's promoting it and he made comments
about the me to movement and his friend
Roseanne and louis c.k and here's what
he said he said I'm happy to me to
movement has slowed down a bit
it used to be 100 women can't be lying
then it became one woman can't lie and
that became I believe all women and then
you're like what like that Chris
Hardwick died I really thought got the
blunt end of the stick there he went on
to say his friends the unlike the
victims his friends
the comedian suffered more than the
victims did that he had to apologize
that was over-the-line however there
might be another reason that Fallon and
The Tonight Show that Jimmy Fallon went
to to ignore McDonald and said my
producers are in the other room crying
so you can't come on the show he said
something about his talk show as opposed
to the ones that are already on the air
this is what he said this might explain
his cancellation as well he said ever
since Jon Stewart late night hosts have
been forced to make become political
pundits you know even down to Jimmy
Fallon and he is derided for his
treatment of Donald Trump and then to be
maligned for quote unquote humanizing
Trump funny I thought he was human if
you have a nominee for president on your
show and he's your guest then he is your
guest Oh Fallon had to apologize for
having Trump on basically right remember
he messed up his hair they say he
humanized them but what we reach a point
let's add that a present president is
human and that's controversial we've
really reached a low point now whether
you're watching this nor McDonald show
or not Laura there's a new series on
Instagram TV I know you don't even know
what that is Instagram it's there it's
their new TV service it's called here's
the deal and it's a 10 episode issues
driven show designed to spur young
Americans to vote in the midterms
now who would you think would host such
a show Lord and they asked me I said no
I'm Marni busy on well they found the
perfect host to attract those young
voters Vice President Joe Biden folks
with less than 100 days until the most
consequential election of our lifetime
we've got to keep our eye on the ball
that's why I'm partnering with attention
on IG TV to break down the issues we all
should be voting on this fall not
complicated policy wonk language or
confusing acronyms just facts at least
as I see them voters but I feel like
he's about to sell me a reverse mortgage
when she's not gonna be talking about
Democratic dating he's gonna be talking
about carbon dating selling his shares
yeah retired okay but anyway he went on
to talk about one of your favorite
issues that'll really get the young
people out in the pot immigration Oh for
centuries our tradition of welcoming
immigrants from around the world has
given us tremendous advantage we've
gotten the best of every nation we do
need to control our border every country
needs to control their border but that
does not require ripping infants and
children from the arms of their parents
this administration has to stop using
immigration as a political tool to
divide us into US and them if you're
going to do political punditry on
Instagram TV where's the Newt Gingrich
channel the Dick Cheney channel have
balance these things are all left we
always have been it's a social media has
been dominated by the left with a
tuition is coming where they go all
right here we come
okay that's gonna be very quickly out
real quick the spreading of disease
Laura in your public bathroom a new
study you know those jet spray it's kind
of water and they did a study now the
Journal of height Hospital infection
these are supposedly hygienic you know
what they do they aerosol bacteria feces
and wait wait for e.coli into the air
dinner you're actually getting a face
full of all of this stuff the new facial
the surfaces oh well that's one that
wait a second do you say the Journal of
hospital injection Hospital oh no
where's my subscription that subscribe
when you're crawling and somebody else's
don't like use those things here this is
what I'm giving you ah thank apricot I
don't use those jets praise their bet
right in your face its Hormuz you can
use is that the unseen or that is the
unseen exact area unseen ecoli growing
on your side